إنها حادثة مأساوية مروعة حوالي الساعة
700 مساءً.
تلقت شرطة بلدة ميدلتاون مساء الثلاثاء مكالمة هاتفية من
والدة جاستن مو تقول إنها عثرت على
زوجها مايكل موان البالغ من العمر 68 عامًا ميتًا
وفقًا لشكوى جنائية
حصلت عليها شبكة CNN عندما وصل الضباط،
وجدوا رجلاً مسنًا في الحمام
والدماء حوله  الذي تم
قطع رأسه، عثر الضباط على منجل
وسكين مطبخ كبير في حوض الاستحمام،
وقالت وثائق المحكمة إن الشرطة عثرت بعد ذلك على
رأس مايكل مو في كيس بلاستيكي في
وعاء الطبخ في الغرفة المجاورة، وعندها فقط
علمت الشرطة بمقطع الفيديو الذي
نشره ابنه على موقع يوتيوب والذي  بقي على
الموقع لمدة 5 ساعات تقريبًا قبل أن يتم
حذفه في مقطع فيديو مدته 14 دقيقة ونصف،
جاستن يتذمر من
إدارة بايدن على الحدود ويصف
والده بأنه خائن لبلاده لأنه
كان موظفًا فيدراليًا ويقول "
أمريكا متعفنة"  من الداخل إلى الخارج
بسبب الغوغاء اليساريين المتطرفين، قام جاستن
بعد ذلك برفع رأس والده المتوفى
أمام الكاميرا، أنا حزين جدًا على
العائلة، أنا حزين جدًا على المجتمع الذي
تعرفه، وكذلك على الأشخاص
الذين عرفوه أثناء الشرطة  كانا في
منزله، على الرغم من أنهما كانا متجهين غربًا،
وقال متحدث باسم وزارة الشؤون العسكرية والمحاربين القدامى في بنسلفانيا لشبكة CNN في حوالي الساعة 900 مساءً.  تم
تعقب الهاتف الخلوي لمون إلى
خارج
قاعدة الحرس الوطني في فورت إنديانتاون جاب،
ومقر الحرس الوطني في بنسلفانيا على بعد حوالي 100
ميل من مسرح الجريمة، وقالت PMVA إن
موان كان مسلحًا بمسدس ولكن تم
القبض عليه في النهاية دون وقوع أي حادث بينما
تحقق السلطات مع
زميله السابق في السكن.  قال جاستن لشبكة CNN إنه
يعتقد أن الاقتباس من الحكومة كان يهدف إلى
جعله يتأوه، كما رفع عدة
دعاوى قضائية تشير إلى أنه كان غاضبًا من
وضعه كرجل أبيض، وهذا
الحادث المزعج يجدد المخاوف
بشأن خطر العنف السياسي، وهو
نوع من
الخطاب المتطرف المحموم والمسيّس بشدة الذي  ما نسمعه أحيانًا
في هذا البلد له تأثير فعلي
على هؤلاء الأشخاص المهمشين ذوي
الآراء المتطرفة، داني فريمان، سي إن إن باكس
كاونتي
بنسلفانيا